[Music]
nope
your eyes aren't playing tricks on you
that's addison ray and bryce hall in a
new tick tock video on her account
and they literally can't keep their
hands off each other
yeah hey addison just two months after
the two called it quits
they hopped on the app's promiscuous
trend lip-syncing to the popular
throwback
nelly furtado song but it's the hand
under addison's chin
as he pulls her in for an almost kiss
that really did it for me
like the whole thing feels very couple-y
oh and get this bryce also shared a
boomerang of shave time on his
insta story tuesday and who's that
rubbing shaving cream on his face
you guessed it addison right now i'm
kind of just going with the flow and who
knows
what'll happen yeah her face isn't in
the clip but some
eagle-eyed fans were quick to note she
was rocking the same multi-colored manny
just
a few days prior we've been hanging a
lot hanging out a lot recently
so it's unclear if these two are
officially back on
but when e.t caught up with addison and
her mom sherry in september
she said the timing between them just
isn't right at the moment
there was a lot of times we were on we
were off and it was kind of just like a
a confusing situation but um
right now we're just kind of both
deciding that you know
there are a lot of things going on in
both of our lives that we really need to
focus on and
um and figure out i just really want to
focus on my family my brands my
um my career and just really trying to
shape
my life for the next five to ten years
and i think bryce also has a lot going
on
and and things that he has to figure out
as well and i wish him the best of luck
in it all and i think
um at the end of the day um we're both
still
you know wishing the best for each other
but the 20 year old social media
superstar
didn't exactly rule out the possibility
of getting back together
in the future i'm kind of just living
life day by day and
we're still young so i'm really not not
too worried about anything i think at
the end of the day
there's a great plan in store for my
life and if that's
involving bryce or not it's going to be
part of the bigger plan which is
going to be great and a few weeks later
bryce told et
the decision to split was mutual despite
rumors that
he broke up with her it was
like kind of mutual it was both of us
agreed we're still really good friends
uh last time i talked to her though
probably a few days ago we don't talk on
a daily basis but yeah
[Music]